babies are people from the very
beginning we can know this with
certainty simply by using our faculties
of reason but let's look closer for
evidence and all the facts that the left
doesn't want you to know within the
first four weeks of pregnancy
the baby's eyes face mouth jaw throat
and heart will begin to form today you
can kill that baby anywhere in the
country by six to eight weeks the baby
has ears the beginnings of his brain
spinal cord nervous system digestive
tract sensory organs and bone by this
age she has a heartbeat in 43 states you
can kill her by 16 weeks a baby has
fingers toes eyelids eyebrows eyelashes
fingernails hair teeth bones a
functioning nervous system and fully
developed genitals at this stage she can
suck her thumb and yawn and in 43 states
you can kill her by 19 wakes you can
feel your baby move and also in 41
states you can kill her by 21 weeks your
baby can respond with movement to the
sound of her father two sounds outside
of her mother's body at this point your
baby can survive outside the womb and
also in 40 states you can kill her by 23
weeks your baby's eyes will open she
will have visible fingerprints and toe
prints and she will very likely survive
if born prematurely also in 29 States
you can kill her at this point the laws
begin to get blurry 22 states then
impose certain degrees of legal bans on
killing fully formed viable infants
notably seven states do not nothing at
all Oregon is a great example of this
Oregon has had no abortion restrictions
for the past three and a half decades
that means a mother can murder her baby
as she gives birth with no penalty at
all and Oregon is not alone among these
barbaric states even states like New
York New York purports to have
restrictions on abortion but they don't
they actually leave the door open to
abortion at any point up until birth
through vague language regarding quote
threats to the life of the mother to be
clear abortion
is never medically necessary but by
pretending that it is infanticide
ippolit ition such as New York's
Governor Andrew Cuomo can hide the
enormity of their laws such as the
recently passed reproductive health act
this law in practice permits abortion up
until the moment of birth it actually
goes even further to amend the New York
penal code such that prior to the law's
passage if you killed a pregnant woman
you'd be charged with double homicide
after this psychopathic law was passed
that penalty was diminished you would
only be charged with a single murder
Andrew Cuomo when he signed the bill
into law had the audacity to say God
bless you all to the pro-abortion
politicians he then lit up the World
Trade Center in pink better to have lit
it up in red